I know again to the war in Ukraine now
and kiev's forces are continuing to
withstand a barrage of Russian assaults
in the eastern city of bakmut tens of
thousands have died during the battle
for the city it's hugely symbolic for
both sides and the fight for it started
seven months ago joining me now retired
Air Vice Marshall Sean Bell hello again
to you Sean so what is the latest on the
ground
across the country and our Russia
advancing yeah there's a lot to cover
but in principle the 1200 kilometers the
front line is still pretty active but
the main focus has been around cremina
to the north up luhans the yellow area
to the north just of back moot there the
Russians seem to have made very limited
progress and fighting appears to have
virtually stalled volada which is down
to the south of Bak moot there intense
fighting in the past but again the
Russians seem to be making no progress
at all in bakamut though if we focus in
on Bak moot that's where the most
intensified team led by the Martin group
we've been reporting recently that the
uh the bahamuta river which runs up
north south down the middle Russians had
taken the Eastern side the ukrainians
held the western side the the news at
the moment is that Russians have
actually got some beach heads now across
the river and have actually made it
across it they've got a little in
placement they've now managed to afford
the river and they've now got some
military forces on the western side but
the harsh reality is that they're not
actually making significant progress
of their what's the key thing really
though is that
um the the fightings as you say be going
off for months here but over the last
few weeks they've been between 90 and
100 attacks per day on the front line
that's actually diminished now to
between 20 and 29 so it's about a third
of the level activity now any offense
which the Russians have been trying to
do for the last two months is incredibly
draining on resources in a Manpower you
generally Surge and then stop replenish
and then go again and any military mind
at the stage would be going right Russia
needs to pause collect its thoughts
refocus its resource and go again but
there does seem to be political pressure
for them just to keep grinding away at
this and they're not making great
progress well what's causing them to
struggle is it just that political
pressure to keep going or are there
other issues at play there's a
fascinating Dynamic going on at the
moment part of that there was a time
when it suited President Putin use the
Afghanistan down on the left of the
screen there who runs the Vagner group
mercenary group largely convicts to uh
to mount his operations because he
judged that it didn't matter about the
the levels of casualties they were
convicts and it brought him time to
mobilize more forces but progression was
quite successful his forces were quite
successful and his influence started to
rise uh grazimov on the right who's the
head of the army started to get really
upset about this because actually
there's always a conflicts of resources
so he's clearly been given direction
from Putin to actually start succeeding
on the battlefield and and Whittle down
pragos in as a result of which
gerasimov was told to look after validar
he's made no progress there pregozian
was left in charge of backwood and he is
making progress he needs more ammo but
that gets provided by the Russian army
and the Russian army has not been
providing the ammo they've also turned
off his access to convicts so it does
does seem to be a joint effort between
Putin and grasmov to undermine
pragosian's position now this is really
interesting because War should be about
prioritizing your military resources
focusing on Military aim it shouldn't be
a battle of egos which is what this is
turning out to be on the Russian side
and what the sacrifice they're making is
huge casualties as a result of this
friction at the top
okay let's talk about planes fighter
jets mig-29s in particular Slovakia have
just said that they're going to give
their old Fleet aren't they so is to
Ukraine obviously so is this the first
sign that we're seeing the West saying
yes we're going to give you fast Jets
yeah it's worth the background it's
worth noting that both Poland and
Slovakia are both of close to the front
line of NATO's Eastern flank and whilst
they're the buffer zone is Ukraine and
Belarus if Ukraine was to fall and
Belarus is in Russia's pocket anyway
suddenly they become the front lines
they're very well motivated to try to
help Ukraine these mig-29s are operated
by both those countries and Ukraine for
being offered by Poland not clear how
many from um Slovakia the trouble is
they only had 11 they were all taken out
of service last summer it's not clear
how many are actually serviceable at all
positive side at least the Ukrainian
Pilots know how to fly them the
maintenance guys know how to maintain
them and extra spares would undoubtedly
be of value the downside is they're an
old airplane they're 40 years old not as
good as the Russian airplanes and
therefore it's unlikely they make a
significant difference it does give them
more quantity but doesn't give them more
quality okay sure thank you